oui bien sûr c'est important de l'avoir
comme on l'avait fait à nîmes c'est
c'est important de voir que dans sa
diversité avec ses sensibilités bien la
droite et le centre sont unis sont
rassemblés et font campagne ensemble et
pour nous c'est essentiel encore une
fois toutes les élections territoriales
nous les avons gagnées dans cet état
d'esprit donc on connaît les recettes de
la victoire on sait aussi comme on
échoue à chaque fois que l'on à des
divisions des aigreurs
et bien et mon père dont convient que
quand on est rassemblé
non ce sont des gens qui sont dans une
même famille politique parce qu on est
dans une même famille politique on est
obligé de partir en vacances ensemble
mais en tout cas on a et on est capable
de porter de se rassembler autour d'un
socle de valeurs et d'idées et si le
travail que nous avons fait depuis deux
ans républicain sur lequel tout le monde
se retrouve aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
de débat sur la ligne la ligne allait
trancher elle été tranchée par les
militants et quand vous prenez les
propositions des deux chacun des
candidats ont leur tour on se retrouve
parfaitement par rapport à notre projet
ensuite chacun la capacité bon à
l'incarner à le porter et c'est à ça
qu'on les tempéraments des uns des uns
et des autres mais de voir tout le monde
et tout le monde aux élèves c'est
effectivement une belle une belle
satisfaction
c'est pas bien
je pense de moins en moins et ce qui est
prévu aujourd'hui vous voyez de voir
tout le monde ici aussi hd républicains
tout le monde à nouveau reclus dans la
famille des républicains bon je pense
que c'est une belle première étape
sénégalais
non parce que je pense qu'ils savaient
où se trouvait ce
qu'on fait avant le 4 ou pas et combien
on en fait voilà c'est ça qu'on va
trancher demain et puis sur la forme si
on va
faire des propositions très sérieuses
aux médias
je cherchais pas j'ai pas non
c'est de leur responsabilité
et tout le monde sait bien que notre
électorat plus que n'importe quel autre
électorat est attentif à l'unité et au
rassemblement
et donc voilà je suis pas inquiet pour
cette raison parce que c'est leur
intérêt personnel et c'est notre intérêt
commun
c'est jacob tous les candidats réunis
toute la presse française au rendez vous
la peau de trémie est ce que la journée
c'est pas parce qu'il effectue en
interne c'est la guerre dont
aucune affaire tout est un peu sérieux
vous pouvez voir vous savez moi qui ai
connu chirac balladur copé copé fillon
le groove éclaté en deux et cetera
croyez moi
on est vraiment d'abord on est dans un
très bon état d'esprit et avec une vraie
volonté d'olivier mais c'est important
effectivement de le montrer que les
français sachent voilà que les les
dirigeants non seulement ce cas on
travaille ensemble mais c'est sûr sont
sur un même socle idéologique et avec un
programme de fonds qui étaient établis
par les républicains et tout ça se fait
ici au siège de républicains
[Musique]